detrás del pelo rubio el destino roto de
Morgan una mujer iraní perseguida tanto
por el régimen como por sus familiares
huyó de su país hace cinco años
una noche mientras iba en bicicleta
empezaron a insultarme y agredirme me
detuvieron no solo por ir en bici la
policía me dijo porque contestas No
deberías ir en bici no deberías
defenderte sobre todo después de mi
divorcio tuve muchos problemas la gente
en Irán tiene una visión diferente de
las mujeres divorciadas los hombres en
cuanto se enteraron de que está
divorciada se les metieron malas ideas
en la cabeza la gente abusaba de mina
dime protegía por eso me fui de grano
llegó su la Grecia donde le concedieron
el estatus de refugiada sin ninguna
ayuda marcan vivió en la calle y sufrió
nuevas violaciones y agresiones sexuales
hasta que hace unos meses decidió huir
pero al intentar cruzar de Francia a
Inglaterra la policía francesa La detuvo
la prefectura amenazó entonces con
deportarla a Irán Hoy es el Día de la
vista su abogado ha presentado un
recurso entre sus argumentos legales el
estatus de refugiada de margan que
normalmente hace ilegal devolverla a su
país de origen la audiencia a la que no
se nos permite asistir será decisiva
para ella
se espera que el juez tome una decisión
la semana que viene según nuestras
informaciones al menos otras dos mujeres
iraníes han sido detenidas Y actualmente
las autoridades francesas las amenazan
con expulsarlas a Irán
desde hace varios meses existe un
comunicado de prensa procedente
directamente del Ministerio del interior
que anima a los prefectos a hacer amplio
uso de su poder de imponer obligaciones
de abandonar el territorio la presión es
tal que los comisarios ya no actúan con
criterio
intentamos contactar con la prefectura
pero no respondió a nuestra solicitud